Edward data Heroes I'm the chief
scientist of data Heroes ethernetzer and
we're going to talk a little bit how you
can use corset to improve your machine
learning models both in building them
and in maintenance
okay so a little bit about me you were
asking about uh your degree so there you
go
um I have a BSC Computer Engineering
from the technion I did my master
physics on how to use brain signals to
teach AI systems bin data center for
roughly 12 years
and had the pleasure to teach a little
bit about Ai and data science both in
the paper and a few other places
the other thing that is not written over
here I started my PhD on a topic that is
named as corset never finish it and uh
stopped it to do data Heroes and we
gotta talk a little bit about that and
why I prefer to make it a product and
not my PhD
so uh building a bell model
using our framework
we provide data here with a framework
for
for building better and faster machine
learning models the way that we do that
we know how to compress your data to
reduce the size of the data using a
small subset out of the data
in such a way that we don't lose
statistical information and those edge
cases of your data set so whatever you
used to train on your full data set now
you can train on a fraction of the data
using the same results now we're not
replacing the original your original uh
stack of machine learning tools you can
keep doing your labeling cleaning
training hyper parameter tuning whatever
you used to do with other Frameworks and
other tools you can keep using them
as we go and you can do pixel data
Heroes at the end of this lecture and
see how everything goes
one more thing I wanted to elaborate uh
vlumber capital is one of our investors
as well as AI found and alumni Ventures
and reflection for them support
okay okay you people in the way were
blocking the signal okay so how we do
this reduction of the data
so of course it's from Big Data to small
good data yeah
in a nutshell what we're doing is we
start with the data sets and the given
cost function we want to optimize
we compute per each data sample instance
we compute the importance of that sample
you can think of importance as the
uniqueness or how much that data point
is affecting your model
okay in a as an idea we construct using
that a probability space using that
important to construct a probability
space we sample collect that probability
space and assign to each
selected
sample a corresponding weight
and now once we have that we can
compute our model or cost function using
that subset with weights and get the
same model that we used to get with the
full data I know that in words is a bit
tricky so let's look on the illustration
you can see over here on the top when
I'm using the full data sets there's a
lot of data it's a mess it's a data
scientist you want to get into your data
actually knowing it's a little bit it's
a bit harder
we are selecting data it's where because
it's a substitute you can say that we
dropped some of the data but because we
are using weights there are another way
that we take them into account we're not
completely reducing them okay they are
taking it out by using the weights
okay so we have the full data set what
we've done with our process that we
compute the importance of each data
sample
we have that we build a course we build
our probability space we selected a
subset out of the data assigned a
corresponding weight and we got this
over here now as you can see I'll let
you see because I'm blocking the image
as you can see this is a much small uh
subset over there comparing to the
original data and due to the words that
were given we compute the same decision
boundaries that we have over here in
both images are the same that are
computed
it's not a marketing uh plot that's a
true plot
that we have the same decision
boundaries for both full data and the
core sets so whatever you wanted to
compute using your full data set you can
do with the small data set now after
we've seen the visual
Administration a little bit of a use
case that we've taken we've taken a data
set with roughly 600 000 instances
and when you complete your computer
logistic regression using the full data
set you have an area in the curve of
roughly 0.78
okay that's pretty much the undercut
that you're getting
uh if you randomly sample
one percent of the data
you really hurt your model you get down
to 0.725 area under curve that's pretty
bad we had to go up until we sampled 15
out of the original data to get roughly
to the same amount of area undercover
that we had before
we know the data we know the cost
function we don't assume anything else
now uh using data Heroes the way that we
selected our subsets
using the same one percent that was
doing horrible over here we got to
exactly the same result as using the
entire data set okay so just a second so
whatever you used to do on the full data
set now you can do on the small data
sets and it's much easier both cleaning
the data running up around my tuning
everything is much easier ESL but that's
from now on let's skip the question to
the end yes
it sounds like something
in the spirit off shops no it's not a
shop score uh because in shop it's per
it's for the features it's something
that is out of the scope of the lecture
uh it's too mathematical for this scope
of a lecture uh but you can always ask
us later we'll have our email on the end
okay
great so now after we introduce yourself
to corset
uh we were already invited to Pi data
and roughly around September and we
already talked about courses and how
they can help you to clean your data
much more efficiently okay so in this
illustration What you see with taking a
data set
we computed the importance of each one
of the instances we've taken uh
instances that had a correct label you
can see those one in blue and we've
taken instances
that the label was wrong and we compute
the distribution of their importance as
you can see
okay as you can see when you look on the
distribution of the clean instances
their importance is much lower
and when you look on the distribution of
the time of sorry of the noisy labels
the importance is much higher so it's a
pretty good uh way to split your data
into clean and unclean instances
okay so that was nice but we want to see
that in real life so we've taken the
well-known data set known as imagenet
and we computed the importance of the
instances over imagenet
and apparently it's quite noisy even
being done a lot of work with it
everybody's using chemistry there's a
lot of noise in images and long labels
okay notice that the results over here
are not the results of the machine
learning model thinking those are
missiles this is the actual label given
in the data okay so you can see in the
first line a few examples that had a low
importance we could all agree that those
are missiles that's pretty easy to see
over in the bottom row you can see one
that had a high importance that actually
incorrectly labeled those two hopefully
are easy to spot that it's wrong this
one is confusing at first but notice
that it's not a missile it's a space
it's a rocket for a spaceshift uh so
it's nice to see that the Mac know how
to identify that we had a few mistakes
in the day that were that were labeled
and given as gold standards
and
we've taken that process
we've taken we've done it the next
experiment you can see on the on the
plot on the left
for every hundreds uh images that we ask
using the importance we ask for high
importance images
we manually uh viewed the images
and you can see that in the y-axis how
many were labeled
as we were going over the images
so as you can see using the corset and
importance in order to clean your data
set from and fixing wrong wrongly
labeled images
that was getting quite high on the
contrary when you do that pretty much
randomly
as you suspect it's very hard to notice
that you have any problems in your data
it's going very slowly now of course the
better data that you have the more you
clean it
the plot on the right shows you that the
accuracy of the model is getting better
and better as well there's no surprise
there
okay so up until now everything I
already told on this kind of a stage of
how to clean your data using corsets
okay now we want to let you talk about
something a bit different
how we can use corset to maintain your
model and avoid data drifts
okay so okay we cleaned our model we
have a good model we moved into
production and the one thing we all try
to to are not not even ignore to not to
avoid to completely ignore the fact that
the degrees keep changing all the time
and the more that you had working great
a month ago is not update with the new
data coming in and need to be updated
now there are enough people and
companies talking about how to detect
drifts in your model we're not going to
talk about that that's not the purpose
of this talk what we are going to talk
about
is the following
so in order to avoid your drifts
basically after you detected it in order
to avoid it
there are only two there are two things
that you want to do you want to
clean up your data the new data coming
in you want to clean up the mistakes
that were done we already talked about
how corset can help you clean your data
coming and make it much more pure and
reduce the noise in your data the second
problem sorry excuse
no I do not Define data drifts I talk
about it generally about the fact that
every time that you have a model up in
production after a few after a while
your data is
keep updating and change and now you
want to update your model the change
that happen in your data
so we already talked about how you can
clean your data using corset now we want
to talk about something different
there's another problem when you try to
update your model that in order to have
to avoid you if you would like to update
your model frequently but cleaning the
data and after the ingredients both
require a pretty high budget to do that
and if you want to keep updating your
model it's a problem because all the
time the training time is growing more
and more
so can we use corsets in order to reduce
the training time that we're computing
so there is a unique data structure
called Corsa tree that's we're going to
discuss about
okay so imagine that you have your your
data you split you split your data into
batches okay in this case we have our
data X1 to x 21
okay we split into batches and now we
already know that we can compute a
corset for each batch
now the next thing we can do there's a
nice property of corset we can take two
core sets unit them together and compute
a corset over them
and get
another layer of corsets and of course
we can keep doing that again and again
again until we get to the root
and now everything that you use to
compute using your food data sets you
can compute and get the same result
using the root C7 in this example
getting the same model as if you were
training the entire data
okay so now we want to take what to talk
about what will happen when we get
another bit of data so the first thing
we're going to do
you're going to put in the corresponding
place in the batch the new batch coming
in that we want to compute and now in
order to update our model all we need to
do
is to update the path C5 C6 and C7 which
is a fraction of the computation needed
to recompute the entire model on the
entire data and now you can very fast
compute a new model using only C7
getting the same results as using the
entire data sets
okay so we have a little bit of a demo
for you guys okay we run most of it
because it take a while and I don't want
to sit like this for a long time okay so
I'm gonna go over it briefly so first of
all uh in this demo we have a few
parameters that are important most of
them are not critical for everyday use
because are pretty familiar with you
guys for example the model parameters uh
the ones that we are using is the corset
size and the chunk size that you've seen
in the previous
slides regarding a Corsa 3. okay so we
imported the data have some
important help function that's not very
interesting
right now we have a data this is 60
million long
okay so as you can see Computing a model
which is logistic regression model
on the entire data set to roughly 40
seconds to run
okay now you can see over here that we
defined a corsetry service for logistic
regression as I mentioned earlier it's
important for us not only to have the
data we also need to know the kind of
cost functional model to trying to to
learn
and we built the tree using that
and as you can see building the tree and
Computing and classifying over the root
of the tree took roughly the same amount
of training on the entire data sets up
until now not very exciting news but
ah and they got roughly the same score
in terms of accuracy
and now we want to add more data okay
okay this one will take a while okay
we're adding more data and training on
the full data set with the added data
meaning that we have more than 60
million samples right now running on the
background we chose one with not a lot
of features so this will not turn into a
exercise workout that I'm doing here
we're squatting over here hopefully it's
done already not yet it will take a
while
Ilya can finish his uh his uh radio if
he wants to
excuse me you can finish a riddle from
earlier we need we need a Time Gap
yeah
yeah a question is a great time Gap yeah
he's trying that on all the different
kinds of data sets models I mean okay
when you say model when you say model I
say cost function we don't have that for
every cost function available in the
world okay we are working on a few a few
of them that we don't have yet we have
most of the classical machine learning
we don't have everything yet regarding
the data set we work on the feature
level so we don't care about how is your
data coming in we care about the future
embedding that you have in the end so if
you're using about talking about NLP
computer vision or anything else that
you can embed into a feature Vector we
are there
great is it done great okay
great so as expected it took almost 30
seconds now if I'll do the same thing
using the corset
that I built earlier all I need to do
now is partial build and add the new
data coming over there and as you can
see it took seven seconds I didn't have
to Gap the time over here now if I want
to compare the results you're getting
roughly the same sorry exactly the same
number in this case
okay so that was very uh convenient for
us
just a second just was very convenient
to us working and updating our data yes
after
sorry what why
[Music]
that was like the fifth digit if I
remember correctly and by the way in
many cases we're actually getting better
results
from uh the original one because for
example psychic learn is optimized for
medium-sized data and a lot of time we
get actually better results using our
method if I was
after the data updates
white went from 79 Ah that's 87. Ah
that's uh that's uh okay sorry I thought
you asked me to be true okay that's
that's depend on that that depends on
the time because because you added now
more data and now uh the drift is less
the new data coming in is updated with
fresh data that was not the purpose of
that demo okay the demo was more for
time
that was not the point of the of the
demo the point was to show the time
constraints if you want to talk about
that we have
we have this that will be more the one
after this that will be more efficient
to talk about
Okay so
uh the training time so we we just
showed that if we want to
frequently update our model okay uh if
you go with an additional method of
adding up all your data coming in using
the full data set
uh we start with having zero new data
coming in and the x-axis is as the data
getting larger and larger from zero new
samples to 20 million samples the y-axis
is the time of training the model
so as expected when you do the
traditional using the full data set
coming in
the training time grows linearly
as as it goes and sometimes the Gap over
here will start to play with the ram a
little bit because you don't have enough
space on your arm to shift between RAM
and other spaces
on the contrary when you use the corsets
three
you can see that the update time is
pretty much fixed actually it's not
fixed it rolls the direct in in the log
but it's hard to see and as the data
gets larger and larger
it doesn't matter because of the Corsa
tree structure
yes
that's the nice thing we're not doing an
online learning or looking just on the
last time window the tree is growing
growing growing and we're not forgetting
okay unless you want that that it's a
feature sorry
in some sense I compress the data uh
it's not uh lossless like Zip
compression it's a substance over there
but in some way I compress the data I
prefer to say that I'm not compressing
it I'm selecting it uh according to the
cost function so it's pretty close but I
prefer to say that I'm selecting it yeah
foreign
those kind of engineering questions is
for the guys sitting two hours behind
you and that's not the right time right
now
um okay
so uh we have that we show that we can
effectively reduce the time to compute
make it affordable now does it even
worth it
[Music]
so that's the same experiment from
before now the only difference now the
y-axis is the accuracy so as you can see
when both models started we had the blue
one updating fast every 10 000 samples
it's being updated with fresh mock with
a fresh model the Red One is updating
much slower using the full data set with
200 000 samples
so as expected when we start both of
them are pretty much similar in results
But as time goes the drift starts to be
more and more effective
and after a while it's becoming of an
issue as you can see after a while the
blue one updating every 10 000 samples
that now we can do because it's
effective cost effective
is getting much better results than the
one that we
slowly opted because we don't have the
budgets for training that
okay now uh we already talked about how
you can reduce your budget we talked
about how it can actually help you
getting a more a better model having a
better results and people sometimes
forget that that's not not that's also
important sorry that was uh that was not
the right time uh the carbon Footprints
uh using data here is a lot winner much
better for the environment because of
the reduction in compute time
the carbon footprint uh is actually
roughly uh
ten percent ten times less than using
the full data sets
so
it's also better for the environment
using courses
okay now the one that I had uh
what's going on with me today okay so
we're not the only one that think that
corset can really help
okay uh
we're not the only one that think that
corset can really help building better
models and faster models
uh Professor randwick shared that Vision
with us and
he also put the money where his uh word
is and he's one of the largest investors
in uh data Heroes
uh and he shared our vision towards
courses
okay so I want to thank you guys for
hearing
um we have a new version
that came out literally today
okay you can either use the link or use
the QR code okay uh if you have any
questions
uh both my email and Iran that's sitting
over here which is the engineering
question towards him so uh go for it
exactly
the Deep mathematics for me okay no
problem we'll work with that uh and I
want to thank uh blumber capital for
having us and hosting this event and uh
by data with my data and the five data
also for organizing this event and thank
you very much and now if there are any
questions now would be the right time
for it yes just a second I didn't
understand and I'm not sure
no it's not model free it's based on the
cost function if you decided that you
want to train uh linear regression and
tomorrow you want to use the same
results that we are providing you to
train okay means I'm not promising
anything I'm assuming that you know the
cost function ahead of time not exactly
the cost of function but the model I
mean the model and okay the future
extraction the model and the cost
function yes yeah that's correct
not only the loss on the feature
extraction we can do sometimes a little
bit uh
a little bit of
um
we can reduce that sometimes that
that's not a that's not the right place
for a wall
um we can work with that sometimes but
in general you need the model the future
extraction and the cost function
s
I'm not going to give the lecture about
the Deep mathematics because it's not
the right form for that you can always
ask us and get like a gazillion articles
about that and we can talk about it it's
uh
we can do that on a on a natural offline
yeah yes yeah
how I saw the opportunity
yeah sure I'm sorry I forgot the video
is there uh he was asking about why did
I stop my PhD for for pursuing this what
was the opportunity that I saw yeah okay
so before prior to doing my PhD I was
working in the industry uh doing
freelance and Consulting work for
companies
and when I started saw a bunch of
problems
and I saw this mathematical deep
mathematical uh topic
I said to myself most of the time is
wasted on waiting for computation and
having too much data that I don't want
to clean it not because it's clean
because I don't want to clean it so this
was the opportunity that I found
combining both the mathematical end and
the more practical end of it
yeah
[Music]
that's a great question I'm repeating it
for the video he was asking if the
computation cost is even worth it
because it sounds like the Computing the
importance itself sounds like heavy
lifting so first of all if you're going
to compute one time your model one time
and one time only don't use us I agree
with that that makes sense even though
when you saw that we were building the
corsetry we're actually faster than
working on the entire data set so first
of all you keep acting your model either
it's hyper parameter tuning adding more
data cleaning your data and rerun your
model A lot of times and because of the
corset so because of the Corsa tree it's
a lot more effective because when you
keep updating it all the time it's much
more it's much easier and you don't need
to recompute the entire computation done
for the model you just need to do it for
the right sample so which iteration
actually is
insufficient because original the
courses for the Delta for the new data
that is coming that you already have
something that's exactly that's one
reason because we can spray it into
small batches and work in met reduce
merge reduce sorry that's one reason the
second reason when we build our
probability space for us it's enough to
approximate the importance to compute
the exact importance it's very hard the
computation process over there is very
hard we are approximating it and when we
approximate it we can do much faster
than
doing then then Computing it so well
the drift of the data will always bear
sorry sorry uh it was asking if the
drift on the there were not remainder
yet and we have to remainder we are
presenting the data that you have if you
have it written your data I'm not
magically disappearing it what I'm doing
is allowing you to recompute your model
before that drift becomes catastrophical
and then your model is giving you more
uh nonsense than real answers yes I
would like to understand the process you
are creating chorus sets for your data
yeah not with the framework the
framework is not creating the course no
no the framework is creating the corset
the framework purpose is to compute
Imports importance create the create the
corset maintaining the course of three
of course and you get a result what you
get in the end you can either use us to
do a fit for your data we have that
building but you could also get from us
the selected samples and their
corresponding weights and do that
wherever you prefer if you want to move
to another platform because we don't
trust us that's fine use it over there
no problem okay is this famous supports
also JavaScript
no no
questions
does the framework support JavaScript no
yeah
right now we support a few of them not
all of them we support k-means
right now mostly uh classical machine
learning host functions okay as you guys
imagine deep learning is a bit more
complicated than other ones uh we're
working at it we're soon to have that uh
right now it's in research mode it's not
yet in available to the General Public
uh we have most of the classical used
machine learning cost Factor because a
lot of for example I don't have the
corset for a naive base because that's
not you don't need me for that that's
that's pretty simple to do it yourself
[Music]
okay no problem
okay so
lateralization or whatever way you
choose the samples you never say that
like the physical
and by some strange coincidence or
perhaps it's my product or the Gathering
of the data that somehow the project
a situation with a group which is life
seem so it's Paradox where the firstborn
said okay this represents the data in
some way the second course
represents the open data in another way
and then the combined part will not do
justice because
that is a great question I I will
shorten it because that was a long
question so for the video what will
happen if the initial corset is computed
was wrong okay
so
uh if we were randomly selecting our
subset we have a uh there is a high
chance of probability that will happen
Okay the nice thing about corsets is
they are mathematical proven with
guarantees so as long as you select a
concept that is big enough as propulsion
to your VC dimension
and
you are
if you want to be really safe you repeat
it more than once
you build the probability space that the
probability that will happen is lower
than the uh
heuristic tools that you're already
using because that same problem you
described that the random C that the
initialization is very bad exists in
everything that we use already okay the
nice thing that we have a guarantee when
it will work
okay so and another nice thing about it
I did not talked in depth into the
definition of importance but it's not
just for the optimal model okay it's for
every model of the hypothesis family
that you're trying to solve for example
this regression just not just for the
optimal line going
over there it's for all of the possible
hypothesis models in that family so we
have a stronger guarantee than
Randomness because even if you are
choosing the worst one will still have a
guarantee if you're of an Epsilon error
that you can control by getting a
smaller or larger course of size
non-burning questions yeah hi let's
follow the elections sorry first of all
thanks for watching I'd like to ask are
there any downsides downsides any
downsides
there is a downside okay if you have a
small data set a very small data set and
you want to use the corsetry we do have
some uh overhead that it's not worth it
you can see that
already not it doesn't worth it if you
have a very small data set
if by mere chance that is unlikely to
happen there is some uh probability to
the building that we're doing there is
some probability so if you have like a
tremendous uh
uh reason not to use probability
methods in your stack then there is a
probability over there but
I think every every solution I'm
familiar with today has some probability
into it
except the overhead if you have small
data sets you cannot think of another
reason not to use it
don't worry we'll solve that very soon
uh when you say time series analysis
sorry he was asking how it will work
with Drive series analysis
in my mind uh
what I care about is the features that
you're gonna build after after from that
time series and how you're going to
organize your data once it's organized
in a metrics and using one of the
traditional
models and optimization methods for
computing something
it's the same how would logistic
regression handle uh Time series
you organize the data in a way that
times that it makes sense for time
series and then run a logistic
regression it doesn't matter okay same
goes here we are not what we are doing
is promising you that will get the same
cost function as the cost function that
you used to use to work with the
logistic regression we're not doing
anything else
uh have you tried comparing the time
Savings of the first three to the attack
settings
a online learning or
to transfer learning a framework we have
not tried that because that's two
different sorry have we tried to compare
our time uh runs to transfer learning on
online learning we're not because
there's a big difference because online
learning and transfer learning has the
potential to be uh biased by new data
coming in so if if for example you have
a great uh transfer learning method but
you only saw a very specific new data
coming in and you don't keep using your
history of how you got there you'll be
very very biased towards new data coming
in so instead of you might be more
feeling to new data coming in and
so-called avoiding the Drift But you
have the other problem that now you
forgot your past and things that you
used to know and used to work for you
are now not as working as good both for
online learning and for
story and for transfer learning
all right last question
that's out of the scope of this lecture
sorry
yeah okay so thank you very much
[Applause]